Is it actually worth it to join a
Toastmasters club?
Every Thursday morning at 6:45 a.m. I
come down to downtown Kelowna to the
Royal Anne Hotel to this room where our
Toastmasters club meets. And I've been
doing this for more than a decade
because I truly believe it is worth it.
Not only have I improved my public
speaking skills over the years, but I've
become a better listener and I believe
I've become a better leader as being a
member of this club.
But Toastmasters isn't perfect. And in
this video, I'm going to talk about some
of the best things about Toastmasters
and why I think it's incredible,
but I'm also going to talk about some of
the weaknesses that Toastmasters has and
where maybe there's an opportunity for
it to be better in the future. The first
reason I think you should join a
Toastmasters club is that Toastmasters
is both a playground and a gym.
Let me explain.
When you are in a Toastmasters meeting,
you have the flexibility to be as
creative as you'd like. So, if you want
to test things out and you want to move
around the room as you're presenting,
maybe checking your notes periodically
and then getting up close and personal
with the audience, you have that
opportunity to do so and it's in a safe
environment. The people who attend these
meetings are here to support you and to
offer helpful feedback. And at the same
time, Toastmasters is a gym.
The best way to get in better shape is
to continually go to the gym and work
out and build that habit and I believe
the exact same for public speaking. If
you want to become a better public
speaker, you have to put in the reps.
You have to practice. And I always find
it interesting. I talked to people who
used to be in Toastmasters clubs, and
they say, "Oh, yeah, I did Toastmasters
10 years ago. It was great."
And they talk about it like it's
something they've graduated from, but
it's my firm belief that that's like
saying, "Oh, yeah, you go to a gym? I
used to go to a gym 10 years ago. It was
great."
Well, we know if you don't continue to
work out, you're probably not going to
stay in the same shape, and I would
argue the same for public speaking.
You get rusty if you don't practice
these skills on a somewhat regular
basis, and Toastmasters allows you to do
that every single meeting. Toastmasters
is an incredible program. I have been a
member of my local Toastmasters club for
more than a decade, but it's not
perfect.
And one of the worst things about
Toastmasters in my mind is how formal it
can feel.
Now, I want you to keep in mind that
every club is different, and there are
clubs that are more casual. Thankfully,
that is the club I belong to, the
Kelowna AM Toastmasters club. We like to
have a lot of fun,
but I have also attended Toastmasters
meetings that are very professional,
very serious.
And that's not my style.
I like to be able to have a laugh with
the other members. I like to be able to
shout something out when appropriate and
add to the group dynamic and get the
room laughing,
but not all Toastmasters clubs like
that. And there's a lot of formalities.
When you come to take the stage at a
Toastmasters meeting and you shake the
hand of the Toastmaster, there are
formalities to say such as, "Thank you,
Mr. Toastmaster, fellow Toastmasters,
and guests who are with us today."
And then getting into the presentation
and the reality is
you're not going to use those types of
formalities too often in life.
And perhaps it's good to practice, but
the fact that it's mandatory and that if
you don't include some of these
formalities, often evaluators will
comment on how that was a weakness of
your presentation.
I think Toastmasters is incredible, but
I would argue in some instances it's a
bit too formal. There are many benefits
to joining a Toastmasters club, but
perhaps one of the best is the instant
real-time feedback you get. You see
within any Toastmasters meeting, there
are evaluators and there are speakers.
And the idea is that every single role,
whether you're giving the toast or
you've taken on the grammarian role or
you're giving a speech or you're
answering a table topics question,
there are evaluators
set to give feedback
on those particular roles. And so within
the same meeting that you are speaking,
you are also hearing from somebody else
who has been watching you speaking, who
is going to give you detailed feedback,
which can help you out knowing what you
did well and what you can improve upon.
And what's really cool is even if you're
an evaluator,
there's a general evaluator at the end
of the meeting who evaluates all of the
evaluators and other roles that have not
yet been evaluated.
That instant real-time feedback is
incredibly powerful. The ability for us
to practice these different roles,
practice our speaking, and then hear
directly how we can improve in
real-time. Toastmasters isn't perfect.
It's really, really good. I've been a
member for more than a decade, but it is
not perfect. And one example of that is
I would argue the majority of
Toastmasters speaking opportunities do
not replicate the average speaking
environment that you might experience at
a conference.
I'll give you an example of this. It was
probably 5 years into my Toastmasters
into my Toastmasters experience until I
witnessed the first panel conversation
happen, panel interview. And yet I
attend a lot of conferences for work and
I can tell you that panel sessions are
almost a regular
feature, like 50% of the content that
you see on stage are panel
conversations.
Yet in Toastmasters,
at least in our club, they are very
rare.
And so practicing being a panelist,
being a moderator of a panel,
those are important because there's a
good chance that you might have a better
opportunity to be a panelist than you
will to give a full speech. And yet
there's not a lot of room for practice
with that on a regular basis within
Toastmasters.
Another example is that PowerPoint
presentations
are a little more rare when it comes to
Toastmasters. Again, at least in our
club. So from time to time we will have
somebody use a PowerPoint, but I would
say this is about 10% of the
presentations that we see.
But a lot of presentations you go to at
conferences or events, it's probably the
reverse. It's probably 90% that are
using PowerPoints.
And while Toastmasters is great because
we can practice these speaking skills on
a regular basis,
it doesn't fully
simulate the experience you might feel
at an actual speaking event. This is an
area Toastmasters could improve. Why
join a Toastmasters club? Well,
Toastmasters allows you to practice
basically every element of public
speaking. So there are all these
different roles in terms of speaking
roles. You can give a full speech that
is something you prepare. You can give a
toast which simulates a real life toast
that you might give at an event or at a
wedding.
You can evaluate roles. So you can
practice giving feedback to other
speakers or perhaps one of the best
things you can do at Toastmasters is
something called table topics.
So the idea behind table topics is you
have a table topics master who comes up
to the front of the room and asks random
questions usually attributed to the
theme of the meeting and then calls out
a random audience member of the club to
come up and answer that question.
So you as the audience have no time to
really prepare for your answer. And this
is such a powerful skill to develop
because we are sharpening up our
impromptu speaking skills, thinking on
our feet. And this will help in real
life meetings, at corporate events,
potentially if you do give a speech and
then you're getting questions from the
audience afterward, this helps you
respond to those and think quicker to
give an acceptable
response and to answer the question. And
by practicing this every single meeting
in front of a live group of people it
becomes much less daunting. So as you
can see, there's definitely more
positives than negatives when it comes
to Toastmasters clearly because I choose
to come almost every week for the last
10 years and I will probably continue to
do so for the next 10 years. I am such a
believer in the Toastmasters
organization but I wanted to create this
video to give a candid take
something that's not just all
butterflies and rainbows when it comes
to Toastmasters and talk about the
reality of a couple areas where I think
there is room for improvement. But, let
me know, what do you think? What is the
best What are the best things about
Toastmasters? What are areas that
Toastmasters could improve? Let me know
down in the comment section. And if you
have not yet already done so, please
subscribe to my channel. If you want to
work with me on a one-on-one basis in
terms of improving your speaking skills,
I have a Stan Store link down in my bio,
which is going to give you all of the
information of how you can connect with
me. I also run Speaker Accelerators, so
you can comment below if you're
interested in that and I'll get in touch
with you. And finally, YouTube right now
is recommending a video for you to check
out from my channel. Thanks so much for
watching this one.